we have trouble cooling off when you hit
a high of 1 10
in the afternoon we've had a few
mid-level clouds around don't expect
that to shield us from the heat and
we're going to get a lot of hot sunshine
again today hopefully you're already
getting yourself hydrated getting that
water going while the coffee pots on and
just getting yourself ready to get that
big water bottle ready for the day it's
sunscreen we've got 90s and some upper
80s around the valley this morning even
mid 80s up in aliante in the north end
of the valley 86 for summerlin 87 for
both the lakes the mountains and
mountains edge still some low 90s for
henderson mid 90s for green valley
90 for nellis and sunrise mountain and
close to 90 even out at red rock low 70s
up there at kyle canyon 87 in mesquite
this morning 67 right now for caliani
howdy to all our friends up there in
lincoln county 63 in ely now those
numbers feel really refreshing but even
excessive heat warnings have been issued
for lincoln county i'll show you those
in a moment 83 for indian springs 81 for
prub death valley at 100 hit
122 yesterday in death valley
85 in sandy valley and 91 in laughlin
right now with 71 for tone upon 61 up in
reno hopefully you've got a plan to
bring the pets inside just really short
short
stays outside in the heat let them go
potty bring them back in let them enjoy
the ac
never never please leave your pets in
the hot sun or in the hot garage that's
not an alternative for keeping them
outdoors check on your elderly neighbors
friends relatives make sure that they've
got good working air conditioning that
they're staying hydrated and eating
light meals and light meals are really
key during the hot summer months you
can't eat those big heavy meals limit
your time outdoors and avoid caffeine
and alcohol as you're staying hydrated
with good good fluids water electrolytes
and all of that
these are all excessive heat warnings
for western arizona southern nevada
southwest utah the area is a peach color
right here those are heat advisories for
the higher elevations for the mountains
going into effect this morning and
staying through tomorrow evening
heat warnings already in effect for the
grand canyon the base the floor of the
grand canyon 110 plus so hot there so
we've had a few clouds coming up there's
still some monsoon moisture in arizona
and every once in a while we just get
some residual clouds from it had a few
cells popping up even in lincoln county
yesterday but we're not looking for
thunderstorms just heat 85 at mount
charleston today
111 for las vegas a uv index of 11 plus
our normal high is 105. the record today
113. we're going to be very close to
that 112 tomorrow then temps slide a
little bit into the weekend we'll start
to feel a little increasing humidity and
by monday we're looking for
thunderstorms again bring us some more
rain hopefully monday tuesday wednesday